[Music]
today I'm going to talk about a legend
he is famous for inventing and beating
world-class players like Bobby Fischer
and me hotel that move 1g 3 also he's
famous for popularizing he's gambit he's
also very much known for his endgame
profits and he was eight times US
Champion yeah
Paul banker yes so banker pal who will
become 90 in July so in honor of that
this lecture is dedicated to banker
Powell who was born in a me and France
also a Hungarian American Grandmaster
very famous for the opening the banker
variation the banker gambit and the
banker opening is one g3 and that's how
he beats tall and Fisher now this
lecture would be fairly incomplete
without starting with his most famous
opening the banker he actually told the
story about this that he found this idea
interesting and felt that okay it's it
deserves a try but the more he tried it
the more success he had with it and he
just picked it up from there and he also
wrote a book about it a six this is the
classical banker he takes bishop takes a
six D six 9s v g6
three Bishop g7 so in general in these
banker type of positions black will try
to use the fact that he has open lines
and files that why doesn't have so this
rook is inferior to this already
activated work on a8
we'll see how banker uses the power of
his rooks and positions 97 rook e1 and
now he plays Queen b6 e 4 but 84 invites
a very nice maneuver that obviously
banker chooses immediately I should
banker play in this position yes Nagi as
banker is eyeing the square on d3 and
that is a very bad sign for white I'm
not sure he was conscious about that but
anyways that Knight is headed there we
see to rook b8 no no you're not going to
move your Bishop from c1 they're gonna
be stuck there forever and that's
actually the rut that I can get into if
I'm familiar with this system h3 banker
says thank you so much Knight e5 Knight
takes e5 b3 but then it's too late
because my d3 jump comes and it's kind
of an aesthetic view of seeing that
everything is hanging for white right
now rogue d1 c4 just opening up the
whole position Bishop e3 Queen B for
Bishop d2 and c5
so White has quite a few problems here
yes trouble developing and also
struggling in general see takes it takes
not before in B to rook c8 now blacks
position is so good that he's not even
willing to take on f1 in fact he plays
rook c8 first just emphasizing the fact
that this knight on c3 is in kind of a
pickle queen a3 Bishop takes c3 now that
was an offer he couldn't refuse takes
takes rook c1 in d4 and bishop f1
obviously it's over by now
but he plays rook C - she's very stylish
mate is coming and also if you take I'll
take you and I'll double attack you at
the same time now he played plenty of
other games with this opening but I felt
that this was one of the best highlights
of how active or how well you can play
this type of positions yes you had a
question so this is the first game I
wanted to show and want to continue with
two other games which shows banker
Paul's style of play g3 we can see the
fur reminiscence of one g3 which we will
see in the game he played against
Fischer so c4 c5 g3 this is the
classical English opening and actually
what's exciting about this matchup as
he's playing over Bach is - and game
masters are pitted against each other so
we will see who is the ultimate and game
player in this game Bishop g2 Bishop g7
Knight c3 Knight c63
all very symmetrical even the computer
says it's ultra symmetrical I wouldn't
go that far
neither 3e 5 but other buff wants to
have this between a kind of structured a
3 but banker does his usual plan of
preparing the idea of a 3 B 4 he six
Castle 97 91 preparing this long
strategic plan of night c2 93 95
combined with the potential islet
potential idea of rook B 1 and B 4 ruby
8 night C 2 B 5 B 4 so banker decides to
go for B 4 instead of trying to occupy
the d5 square now if you're asking if
there's some ideas of efore well
obviously white always has to deal with
this idea but let's say I can move my
bishop but at some moments this
sacrifice isn't too bad if the dark
squares
you'll be awfully weak after I bring my
Bishop to b2 so I'd say that banker has
very good compensation in this type of
position so a furball sees no reason to
enter that position C takes before
Knight X castles takes takes rook a5 so
there's some minor differences between
the two positions can we spot the
differences between by its position and
blacks position
yeah de-spawn on she's on e5 is blocking
the g7 bishop and also black has these
weaknesses on b5 and d6 yeah why it is
just faster in battle and banku is
putting heavy pressure on that b5 pawn
Bishop d7 not that over Bach can't
defend at this moment Bishop g5 again
probing a little bit for more weaknesses
and he gets that Bishop takes e7 367 and
now this is an interesting decision
thank you decides to get rid of the
Knights as he feels that this night will
be much stronger in the long run than
any of those bishops Queen b3 just
bolstering that d5 square look up c8
Bishop d5 we should be 894 and now White
has a very nice blockade on the white
squares also a battery which is kind of
annoying for black right now King h8
okay six look at the eight bishop c6 so
now it's clear that banker used all
these moves to get rid of this dangerous
bishop on the 8th it's dangerous because
it can get active in the long run and it
also has a function of defending these
pawns but he plays Bishop c6 hoping to
get an amazing endgame where he has this
amazing
efore night against a terrible Bishop on
g7 takes takes d5 and d5 was a good move
Javert Bach is trying to do something
before it's too late
because after f5 white could play Knight
c3 and positionally this position would
be just terrible
could could even be considered
strategically winning for white so d5 is
played but then
banker plays the night on c5e for in
here banker comes up with a very nice
positional move that stabilizes the
situation in the center how did Banco
proceed here III yes
so in general banker prefers to have the
position closes he has a night and also
if the position closed out closes up
again this Bishop will feel the same
misery as when it was watching the e5
pawn so he thinks d3 Queen things d3
this is a logical decision by Yuri over
Bach obviously it's not going to play d4
because then I'll just push efore and
after f4 and maybe even e5 white will
have a healthy bind so he plays Queen e5
Knight a six-night c5 would be eight oak
d1 now this is a method often used by
elite and grandmasters to gain some time
on the clock they repeat the position
and also they're kind of asking if their
opponent really has any better idea than
just following whatever ideas they have
in mind Ciroc d1 mg8 again one more
repetition getting closer to time
control and that's kind of the added
benefit of repeating nine a six again
but now banker found a plan of rook c5
and as you'll see in many other games
that we will be looking at banker is
using ideas of having a bind to full
effect he's trying to squeeze the life
out of blacks position Queen d6 rogue d5
unfortunately for other Bach is one move
late so he can capture the a6 night
because the d8 rook is dropping so
you'll have to console himself
to have a worse and game upon down but
let's see how banker wins this Bishop f8
night c5 the job is well is done so the
night comes back to c5 ok 793 now notice
that he doesn't want this rook to get
awfully active if the rook wanted to go
to a four or even a two and we'll try to
get active
but banker is trying to force it to stay
passive as he threatens the idea of
taking the pawn ok one check King g2
would be one in f3 just like in the
previous lecture I did white is trying
to gain some time and bring the King as
quickly as possible as that will be the
key to win this and game rook D to
overbook as an endgame expert himself
doesn't want to see that king coming any
closer
efore h5 d 5 so actually over bak is
playing against the idea of King III
because then there's this check and
black would get some sort of counter
play here so bankers in no rush he gets
some more space
he 5 and potentially of f6 outpost that
could be useful for the night on d 3h
for our buck goes for exchanges because
as we know if black would manage the
exchange of all the pawns and then
sacrifice the bishop for the last bond
that would be a drawn and game obviously
that's a daydream but you know if you
are trying to defend you must dream
sometimes she takes h4 Brooke d1
kingi to Brooke h1 so it's no wonder
that banker takes upon he doesn't want
to get into those and games Rob d1 king
he too
we'll be five Oh gage - so uber Bock is
looking for a solution of getting rid of
banka banka response rugby eight takes
b5 King g7 b6 so I think it pushes the
pawn rook h1 but it's not over yet
because let's say b7 you can go rugby 1
and it's not that easy to promote this
pawn and the next thing that our buck
would start doing is start annoying you
and try to exchange off as many pawns as
possible but either Ruby 5 or even
potentially f6 afters moves like Bishop
e7 so no wonder banker plays rugby 7
forcing the King to move rugby 1 f4 now
he 6 he doesn't play because of ideas
I'm not sure of
I guess maybe King g8 because if King f6
then rook takes f7 wins but King Jade
could be annoying
okay maybe e7 although takes takes and
I'm not saying this is dryish but this
can get complicated sometimes so he
plays f4 just playing it strategically
King D - Bishop e3 king c2 would be five
king c3 so you can notice that banker is
method methodically trying to improve
his position he knows he's a pawn up so
he feels that he should be winning
somehow and I think he's that's correct
King c4 Ruby one rook b8 king g5 f takes
g5 King g7 in here even though banker is
known to be a very good PLAs achill
player he's also good at other stuff and
here
Vanka found an amazing move so why to
move and when g6 almost probably take
that pawn
notice that this rook on b1 is the only
piece for black that has any chances of
stopping that b6 pawn if we manage to
cut this piece off you might actually
find the move that banker played King
seats V well I'll just play Bishop e7
and I'm just waiting nine to be for it
then I'll take you there check so that
yes but if you could get rid of that
Bishop maybe yes rook takes F fate King
six
well black Pedro begs b6 but F King
takes a fate then not be four and
miraculously there's no way of stopping
my beep on and even if you do which you
will not I will just push the pond and
even if you sacrifice it I'll have just
too many materials you can't win
both of the pawns and this is easily
winning so this is a very neat sacrifice
by whites so ever buck takes upon but
this is just lost route g6 rook d7 King
d5 84 and slowly but surely banker is
cashing in every seventh game g5 95 just
bringing the night closer 93 95 96
and just the king comes over and if the
rook moves to f1 now just bring my king
closer than sack at the right moment I'm
not even sure if I have to sack slowly
you'll lose because you don't really
have moves and in fact here but is just
winning after Knight takes f7 as king
takes f7 loses to King d7 as this is
child's play for the two and game
experts so a verbal resigned
second game I wanted to show was the
game he played against Korchnoi in this
game it's very interesting in the way a
banker slowly uses space to win the game
takes takes Bishop d2 and now this is
near equal why the hell doesn't really
have too much advantage here but just
look how banker makes it look easy
King e7 look C 1 a 3 so the main idea is
to take away the squares of this night
so it doesn't feel that comfortable look
c8 Bishop c4 Knight a5 Bishop a2 now the
main issue in these positions with black
is that black doesn't have a
constructive plan the only constructive
plan fortunately found actually was to
start exchanging stuff now I think
Knight c4 is not too great
because Bishop takes c4 rook c2 and the
fact is that this night is just going to
be much better than this bishop on c4
Bishop a6
Brooksie one takes takes in b-17 five
and Bank is going to win the same game
I'm not saying it's necessarily winning
but it's very instructive how banker
plays here Knight f3
well he's probing for some weaknesses so
he's planning to go an IG 5-8 692 can
anybody tell me where white is headed
with that night obviously d6 he's going
for that d6 square in d7 94 6 f4 but
first things first he puts his pawns in
a long chain and also on black squares
so that Bishop will never hit target
Bishop f1 king d4 Bishop g2 96:5 so
Coronel is trying to defend most of his
pawns and tries to position these pawns
as far away as possible from the night
might be 5 probing for more weaknesses
and again Korchnoi has no other choice
than to obey plays ship C 1 a 5 e 5 is a
move I'm not sure it's a great one it's
a bit too aggressive now this is
sometimes the way Korchnoi plays he's
very ambitious sometimes too ambitious
so maybe even though I get courts not
his idea of trying to stop the idea of
b4 b5 e 5 could be a little bit too
aggressive but maybe it's still okay
before takes takes so this still seems
defendable as black only has one
weakness and just not enough targets for
whites to win yet we should pay three
Knights c4 and c6 90s
so Bank is slowly probing for more
weaknesses but after king c6 he realizes
ok you're going here to be five and
ahhing my pawn on b4 I'll stop you
now I don't want to see you there King
d7 like c4 Knight e3 but banker is
inviting fortunate to do something also
is taking away these squares from the
bishop
so black play king b5 King c3 g5 but I
think g5 is just too much
I do understand it's getting much harder
for mu to move with black because the
bishop is stuck suddenly so most
probably Korchnoi should have played
Bishop f1 hoping for the best because
this way the bishop on h3 just got stuck
g5 nights c4 takes takes king c6 in d4 h
596 but already banker made progress
this pawn on h4 v on h5 is clearly weak
h4 night c8 and now the night does the
backflip and is headed it's over 97 96
97 king c3 and now the tough part here
for black is that he has no control on
dark squares and he can't do nothing
just watching how banco does these night
pirouettes in these positions h3 9 g8
King c6 Knight f6 King d4 King bee 597
but he's not going back anymore and he's
planning to gobble up that b6 pawn king
c3 bishop a two-night f8
in c69 h7 and as the bishop went too far
away to a to the problem will be here on
h3 and it's just a temple to short of
saving that pawn there because then I'll
take the e6 pawn then you should instead
of Bishop b5 he played king b5 Knight f6
king d4 gave me five MC three nine eight
seven and slowly slowly bankers out
playing Korchnoi Bishop c4 King III king
f2 King g3 and now banker is about to
pick up this important pawn so Korchnoi
must do some action on the other side
but then banker takes that other pawn
which is more important because this
will be a true runner and we'll do the
home run for palm so Knight takes c6
King things before in 94 and the
problems are twofold for fortunately
this pawn will start running while this
f5 pond will also be in danger Knight
takes a 5 B 493 I take sage 2 takes b3
and the problem is that this is two
extra pawns and that's just too much
slowly but surely those two extra pawn
shows and as banker brings up his King
because that's very good to remember
it's important even in Queen and games
although sometimes you need to hide with
your king this is just winning for him
you notice this nice little trick Queen
g7 Korchnoi can't take on f5 because
queen g6 and the H bond is just going to
promote
so he doesn't take queen d8 f6 and black
resigned for a good reason because that
F bond is going to promote just like the
H bond would have alright so let's take
a look at this other game played between
burn and banker so thank you
is black in here black finds this very
good defensive move of rook a seven
the idea being if Knight takes a5 ago
Bishop d8 and then this will be some
nasty nasty threats on your pen night
therefore burn plays c4 by D 496 check
Knight takes e5 Knight c8 Luke c7 and we
get into this end game now White has
very decent chances of drawing here but
we'll see how banco slowly tries to
outplay Robert Byrne Luke c5 I'd be six
so first things first
he's bringing his nice Knight to d5
Bishop c3 but he doesn't blunder mate
engage 7 Luke c6 Knight d5 and we'll
have to find a good way to open up the
position for black how can black try to
gain some more space or its position
f6c 5:45 and he actually goes for g5
takes takes and even though black is not
happy about exchanging it was kind of
forced because black will needs the king
to probe for a win in G to G for again
trying to just put white in some sort of
bind f3 again white is trying to
exchange as many pieces as possible
would be seven we should be four would
be three game g6 rook c4 king f5 notice
in many of these end games the best of
the best players just bring their kings
up the board because they know that it
will be very useful in the long run
Bishop g7 f6 also a good move just
cutting this Bishop on g7 out of play
ship h6 Knight c3 look at 494 obviously
banker doesn't want to take on f3
because Dan white would have realistic
chances of getting a drawn endgame by
exchanging this pawn off and sacrificing
the bishop for one of these pawns so
let's see if Brooke f3 takes just
posting the bishop on g7 and white has
good chances of drawing this so banker
goes for check rook h2 and notice that
he's not doing big things he's just
trying to minimize the activity of the
white pieces like the King on f1 Bishop
e3 92 and he decides that it's time for
a rockin game rook h3 can get v e5 route
g3 okay
now he plays rook a to to be far away
from this king and potentially checks
are much better that way because if I
check you now I can't attack you with
the Tempe I'm already hitting you and
then I'll just go back to f2 when the
time is right
okay to look c6 game g5 so let's look at
this position for a moment what should
be blacks plan here well yeah it
involves some King move activity but
what about our precious little pawns on
f6 on e5 there should be positioned our
pawns that's actually the big question
mm-hmm f v e4 will be the best one and
that's what banker is aiming for king g6
but he's patient he slowly tries to kick
this rock out rook e8 burn correctly
keeps this rook under the pond also
planning ideas of ruiji a check if
necessary King f5 rook f8 Brook a6 now
sooner or later black wants to move
these pawns therefore we need to move
the rook King G to king e4 maybe hinting
at ideas at f5 and checking and going to
King f3 if the rook moves so it could be
a ghost threat but it's kind of annoying
to face in a real game King G for King F
to check can get 5 again it's a similar
position that we've seen but it's not
quite the same so white needs to work on
how to defend rook f7 in e6 already an
achievement for banker as now he will be
able to push his pawns f5
now this is already a clear achievement
this Jeep on will stay there because if
light moves it then I'll have to pass
pawns and that's a realistic winning
chance for black checks ro cafe check
king g6 check king h5 kind of this
waiting bite from giving more checks
because if you do I'll go King g4 you
check again King f3 and now with an
active pastor like that upon and an
active King on f3 this is very very good
for black obviously burn doesn't want
any of that so he doesn't give a check
just plays rook e8 e 4 and rook GA
stopping the King from entering through
g4 Brooksie to gimme one rook c6 so the
plan is to get rid of that rook somehow
you have to row g6 okay Jay King g5
okay faith but it's still not easy
because we'll have to find a plan for
black in general our plan would be to
bring the King to f3 but let's see how
banku achieves that King g4 keV - Luke
g8 up 6 King g5 notice that he's kind of
inviting Byrne to give him a Tempe and
he accepts that extra Tempe that he gets
place king g5 so burn actually has to
move his rook first rook f7 rogue d8
again the king came much closer to where
it wants to be and now he goes back to
the 8th with the rook rook g7 check and
in fact rook g7 check might have been a
mistake
black wants to get rid of the ideas of
route g7 checks
why should have tried to wait because if
you go further then I'll check you and
play a real g5 and I'll have counter
attacking ideas and white has good
chances to hold so burn should have
waited in this position when the study
played rook g7 so where should we go now
with our Kings that's the big question
well yeah well let's just make one move
of king of six obviously we are getting
closer now we give a check and the
problem here is that the book is not
defending this pawn anymore and that was
actually the main point of bankers
maneuvering that this rook after this
hasty check it's not possible anymore to
defend that pawn why doesn't really like
going back to the first rank he'd like
to go III but that just is not too great
because of rook g2 if you come here I'll
check you and I'll win the pawn so
therefore Byrne is forced to go f1 king
he v now as pointed out Kim D for is a
real threat okay five VOC d5 okay five
look D one check King e2
Boogedy three checks again King f2 check
again the problem g3 pawn not defended
has to go back to the first rank rook g2
now and now this is winning because of
the fact that the black king can march
to g5 g4 which was previously not
possible you know even though the king
can chase this rook away that's not
enough anymore
rook b2 comes and the king will come up
to g4 and black will slowly gobble up
the pawn
therefore Byrne resigned all right four
so we saw how banker usually plays he
plays for binds in these classical ways
of trying to grind away and slowly
getting an advantage so last but not
least let's look at the game played
against Robert James Fisher now they
have a big history together
in fact banker Paul withdrew of one of
the candidates tournament just like
Lombardi and that gave Robert James
Fisher the chance to play in the 1970
candidates tournament which he won and
qualified for that full championship and
we know the history Fisher Fisher became
a world champion so in this game banker
plays the banker opening with one g3 and
if you think this is not too popular
these days even though by transposition
in this tournament played recently in
st. Louis Aronian played a very similar
g3 system against Kasparov at the st.
Louis rapid n blitz go check that out
that's very similar g3 Knight f6 Bishop
g2
six well Fischer plays his regular Kings
in the end Grunfeld kind of play so he
goes G six other more Slav like players
would go d5 but Fischer keeps playing
what he likes and goes for this Kings
Indian structure e four d6 d4 Bishop g7
92 now this is banker's way of handling
the position it's also possible to play
Knight c3 castles Knight f3 and this is
what you will see in the game between
Aronian and Kasparov played recently now
he goes nighty - and what really banker
is looking for
he states that this night will be more
useful here I will have ideas of pushing
the pawn later on also I will be able to
build a bide against you and he's going
to try to prove that against Fischer
castle castle e5 Knight c3 c4 would just
transposed to King's Indian waters as we
all know that Knight c3 c 6a 497 and FV
no bankers style feel guess he's next
move
what would banker play in this type of
position
a5 yes
banker loves playing for positional bind
and he will show it in this game as well
he takes d4 a Fischer is an active
player he loves playing for a counter
play
therefore he opens up the position a
little bit just to get a nice little
Knight on c5 and also gets some counter
play against this efore pawn which is
attacked by both pieces h3 now as we
seen previously
h3 moves are very useful as they work
against these Knight g4 jumps
sawaki eight rookie 197 this typical
plan was bringing over the Knight to e5
but the big difference is compared to
King's Indian structures the seats upon
covers this d3 square and also the B 3
square known from these Bronstein games
we know how useful it is to have
protection over that squares on d3 and B
3 so 97 Bishop e3 Queen c7 f4 already
banker is preparing a potential idea of
facing d5 ideas with e5 obviously it can
take but in case if everything goes
wrong he can just play e5 and just close
off this g7 Bishop rook b8 Queen d2 b5
now computers would consider ideas like
b4 immediately or e5 and it's not that
these moves are bad or anything big or
legitimate moves in this position but
banker is consistent with his plan so he
takes some b6 take some b6 and finds an
idea that will put a lot of pressure in
blacks position
what did banker play in this position
b4 b5 yes before a very strong idea by
white as he is making sure that the d5
square will be eternally his 96 + b5
comes the big problem here is that you
have no good ways of defending this C
pawn and if this C pawn disappears this
d5 square will be an eternal weakness
takes takes takes c5 and Benko realizes
he has a firm positional advantage so I
guess on principle he doesn't get into
tactical struggles because why I do that
if you have a good position place Queen
d2 this should be seven rogue d1 rookie
six in here banker found that this is
the right moment to just break through
how did banker broke through in this
position just march through 35 yes and
now this is very tough to face as d
takes e5 is not an option because I'll
just take your knight on these other
Bishop takes g2 King takes g2 in b7
check and we'll have to decide where to
put our king there's the choice of king
h2 thinking f2 let me ask raise your
hand if you feel that you would put your
king on f2 1 2 3 ok who would say that
you would put your king on h2 that's
very interesting
thank you indeed played King f2 and
what's really good about this move King
f2 banker realised I assume that he's
not in a big danger of getting into any
tactical ideas but we only have these
pieces rooks and Queens on the board
these heavy pieces on the board
so we're not far of having an end game
so having your king closer in that case
is a plus King age 2 is also an option
and it's pretty good too but wouldn't
have the extra pluses of the Move King F
to rook dat takes D six out of six well
we are a pawn up there for exchanging is
a good option queen III king f7 how
could we continue if exchanging is not
among the evils Queen f3 we're happy to
have an endgame but of course Fischer
doesn't want any of that now Bank who
comes up with another very nice
technical move obviously d6 pawn is
hanging but banker finds very very
classy idea in this position Queen c6
are viously an option but is that the
only way to defend that d6 pawn just a
hint that banker even though likes to
play for a bind if he sees tactics he
uses it to maximum extent and he uses it
to get a huge grip on the position and
that's just what happened here as well
so the move is nighty 4 takes takes the
question is what banker was preparing if
rook takes d6 was played by Bobby
Fischer
that's little cheeky move of Queen 85 as
the Queen on b8 is an x-ray and that
would be in a slight trouble now we say
that all rook d8 but banker thought
about this as well rook d7 check and
black is just lost if you go e 8 I just
take on e6 if you go f 8 I just
checkmate you this is a very very nice
tactic that banker found and now his
position is just winning Queen c6 now he
plays queen c6 after exchanging of those
pieces King f3 just defending the pawns
also moving the King into safety in g7 g
4e 5 banker is not afraid of ghosts he
takes that pawn rook f7 and not everyone
plays like tall he went King G - he went
King G - because this is safest
obviously table would go king he for
king d5 and be happy but that's a
different story in that stall but banker
realizes he's winning so why go crazy
and do aggressive stuff like that in G -
in h4 rook f1 enough to take stakes
I mean take 6 3 twin G - Queen III Queen
e2 Bobby Fischer resigned yes if why
play black plays this check and he did
white will eventually just hide with his
king and then these pawns on e5 and e6
will decide the game so this was a game
played by the legendary Paul banker
who's going to be 90 in July so I hope
that you learned how to play like a pro
banker pal
[Music]
you
[Music]